I'm dr. Keller and chances are if you've
had a bad hangover it's been after a
night where you mix a bunch of alcohols
all at once and there's a reason for
that different alcohols have actually
different properties and even though
ethanol is the same in all of them
that's the thing to get you drunk it's
the other additives and things that
happen during the distillation and
fermentation process that give each
alcohol its own specific quality so
something like whiskey is going to have
a very different effect on your body
than something like champagne once you
start mixing them all together it's a
little bit like someone who's mixing a
bunch of different drugs even though the
main drug is the same it's all of the
other things that are gonna give you a
really bad hangover the next day tip for
me
stick to one kind of alcohol be loyal to
it the whole night through and the next
morning you're gonna wake up feeling a
lot better off I'm dr. Keller and
there's a hangover tip for you